of understanding those vocabulary and
actions and commands so in docker this
is thing called an image an image is the
wrapped up package everything in a
doctor environment it has the files of
the operating system operations of
environment variables and other things
that might affect affect your work
that's the package and the package that
can move around when you take that
package and a run it and create the
machine that's running in an isolated
environment that's called a container so
you have an image that's static and a
container that there's also something
called a docker file the docker file is
merely a script that runs a series of
commands that creates an image so an
image can be a big thing it's megabytes
and gigabytes of information because it
has all the file systems all the
installs the script is just what apples
that you can be just a short series of
commands that define these dependencies
inside it and then there's something
called docker hub docker hub is a
service online where people can share
docker images and one of the things
about within it docker hub is not the
only place you can do this much like the
pub and get lab and you can have private
instances and do it on your own services
but doctor hub is by far the most
ubiquitous and widely used answer of the
default of most people go to when
they're sharing things that we put
images so this is object you think of
then there's the actions so give a bare
minimum of commands docker is a lot like
git it's a program that you're running
on your computer
everything you do starts with the word
docker then there's reason and then a
million that can be on it but ultimately
you're really only doing the variance
and that was just this short number of
them but all the slide yup in addition
to my talk and I'm also gonna have a
bunch of code up there for you to see as
well so you don't have to worry about
examples - so has the docker pull which
means you're gonna get an image from
another repository from maybe your
organization's croc there's docker bill
which is takin that docker image to give
it a name so that you can use it again
when you haven't you can if you put say
doc give an image name it'll container
and container is an isolated environment
you usually have to specify how you want
to get data in and out I communicate
with it and for that there's usually
specified you get the communicative the
machine whip which is sort of happy to
communicate via uh no poison Sheridan
the isolating computer running inside it
you might specify some other commands
about what you want to him it didn't
portal a default one and you may or may
not say detach and a painter in the
background for front of you as it's
going and then container doesn't there's
doctors there are a thousand other
doctors commands but this is probably
most of what you're going to use and
you're probably gonna use a some of
these because one of the nice things
about docker wrong is if you stuff it'll
purple or you specify matically built it
hasn't been built already through very
these commands are generally run and can
a terminal with our and all these things
can be done in our as well
our being are there are at least three
packages for running doctor suprise
surprisingly I mean they're actually all
they're all pretty good and they all
pretty much do the same thing and the
API for them is not that different so I
don't have a released recommendation as
to which one you use I like this one
called stevedore it's partially because
of my friend rich [ __ ] John has written
it partially cuz it has some particular
small advantages that I like but it's
not super important most of these things
work the same so to do all the things
that I just described that you would do
in the terminal you can do it in our by
loading the stevedore library you start
what's called the docker client just so
it's communicating with the docker
software and then just like in the shell
you can pull an image with an R function
you can build an image with an R
function you can take an image and start
a container with it
specifying your command and you can stop
that container and you can do this all
in your AR console your R scripts as
well so why would you actually use this
this is actually the part that I think
like most introductions to the docker
kind of skip over because they assume
you know why you're using it and or they
like assume a particular reason for
using it and that can vary a great deal
whether you're a person who's using it
to build a web service or trying to
package a scientific analysis
all of which you might be using in I
sort of break these up into four major
categories of how you might be using
docker one is largely about
reproducibility to like build a working
environment that you can be sure that
things will run the same way and from
place to place that's one of those sort
of sort of core RR reasons the
reproducibility but you also might be
using docker to run a different program
for our to access to call you might be
using docker to run an AR thing that you
want to do
sprint program or service to call or you
might be using docker as a way to ship
around Oh sort of intensive compute jobs
so they can be run on different
infrastructure all those things share
some components but there are different
sort of patterns of working if you're
working in a fixed environment what
really matters is what's inside the
container on top of the whale so what
you want when you are working on a
primary our analysis within a docker
container is to have all the tools that
you want to do your data science process
your analysis within that be it our our
studio the data the extra libraries you
might be using and you want all those
all packaged inside in such a way that
they're like locked and they're a time
capsule and your colleague or yourself
six months from now after you've
upgrading your operating system can I
run those things so it's really just you
know it's the lock box in this case when
you're doing something like this you
have let me skip this is an example of
why you might want to use doing thing
like this so this is a screenshot of the
Tauri of mine associated with a bunch of
work we didn't EcoHealth alliance and
publish the paper associating with it
and we tried to do a really good job of
making it possible for other people to
also run this okay so we made a make
file so we could you know run one
command to do all the different
components of it we use packrat
to save our packages you know we have
extensive documentation you see the
bottom of the description the file tree
of what all the files are and as I was
writing it up I said okay well you need
all these packages we have packrat and
we have a make file and we have this
description and also you need Tyrone
geology Osen magic and Java and coral
and PNG and all of these things and you
know at the time I did not think to put
the verb the you know and you know we
did manage to run it on two different
computers so it did actually happen at a
certain point
kale is in the back smiling there
because his laptop was the one that took
of days for it to happen on but you know
like these super patches shift around
the pieces and I don't know if we wrote
down everything the one needs to do for
this and then you end up with this
problem which was really well outlined
by this paper last year in Nature
Biotechnology where even if you get the
thing to run people have slightly
different versions of the software and
so someone gets a result where you get
significant results and you know here
the answer is 2:23 but then someone
tried to run my software and they got
228 like oh no you have to downgrade
because we there was a bug that we got
around in this way but if you use the
bug fix then you're gonna get something
else didn't on Mac running and Linux and
they get a different answer but you'd
rather have is everyone running the
thing in the same box so the tool you
have for that is for our users in docker
is this great thing called the rocker
project the rocker project was started
by Carl betta turrent or kettle mattel
carl is one of the founders of our open
sigh dirk you may know of as the creator
of our cpp for putting c++ programs into
our they've created this great project
where they have a huge number of our
base docker images that let you want
about having to design the whole set up
themselves what they do is provide whole
library of docker images that have
different sets of packages installed
different associated operating systems
and system libraries and they have it
for every version of our going back five
years you know going back to each patch
version so all of these stacks like you
may want just base are you may want our
with our studio installed in it you may
want our with all the tidy verse
packages on it and you may want that our
three point three point two and you can
just grab any of those off of docker hub
under the rocker
organization in order to run at that
particular image and then you can modify
those for your particular that's going
back and doing all the startup
components so let's take a look at how
one actually oh I have an analysis
that's very important done a lot of
important research to show that there is
a relationship between GDP and life
expectancy in the world and I want to
make sure that anybody else can run that
and that I would be able to run that in
six months from now or can I print
infrastructure that I'm currently doing
now so I didn't find that most of us you
know that we have we have a script maybe
a git repository a set of data all these
components that we need to reproduce the
analysis we also have to define the
environment a docker file the docker
file is just a series of imperative
commands to define it there's a very
simple docker file because it only has
to do a couple of things because we're
going to start the docker file by saying
we're going to use as our basis for it
using the from command the rocker Tidy
verse three point three point two so I'm
gonna have an image that installs our
and the tidy verse and it will use a
version 3.3.4 the package is associated
with three point three point two I have
one command that just means tagging it
with my names that people can know where
this image came from and then I have one
command to install a dependency so I use
the run command to run a line which is a
shell script which is install a package
because Gapminder is the package that is
not in the tidy verse but as part of my
analysis
a dependency and then the final line is
just to add the file analysis dot R into
this docker image and we're gonna put it
in a folder called home our studio so we
think I need to run this that can be
shipped around is defined in this docker
file and all I have to do is build my
environment with a few dr commands so
the docker build command here lets me
build tagged the image as my analysis
and just specify the folder that i'm
doing which is example one a rocker if I
get this right no problem
can I run that in a terminal and what it
does is each of these steps so grab the
rocker tidy verse image three point
three point two I have previously
downloading this and I have in my
computer if I hadn't it would have
pulled it from the docker hub I wasn't
sure about the Wi-Fi connectivity here
so I put all these on my cuter ahead of
time but just pull that thing down and
then it goes to each of the steps it
runs ads the maintainer tag it runs this
script once again I'm speeding things up
by the fact that docker automatically
having built this before is saving these
build commands in a case and so if I
didn't have that it would actually see
that you know the installing package
component and then I add the file it
builds the image and then it tags it and
I called it my analysis if I don't give
a sub tag it always calls it latest so I
have an image and you turn an image into
a running container with docker run so I
can run this docker image with docker
run I'm going to attach it to a port
this says make the seven eight seven my
party at seven eight
and on this thing called my analysis and
they run it in the background so I run
that it gives me a very long tag which
is the name of the image but if we use
the command docker PS it will list
docker containers running and in
addition to a long confusing hash for
the name who also gives a name in this
case priceless coltan docker always
gives an adjective in the name of a
scientist to give your containers unique
name and so that's a step fired up
eleven seconds ago off the my analysis
image and it has port 8 7 8 7 8 7 8 7
and we are placed into an art studio
environment so you can see that we are
running our three point three point two
here which is different my computer is
running three point five it has the tidy
verse packages and the Gapminder package
it has and so I can run everything in
here exactly as I ran it elsewhere and
if I ship this image to somebody else I
push it to docker hub anyone else can
run this the same way now built things
get more complex so that's the nice
thing about the rocker project it has
all of these pre-built images that have
most of what you want but they're a
bunch of other interesting tools for
getting your docker file environment
together particularly for our so one of
these is the container it package
container impact scan your directory of
file or a load your session info figure
out the current birth the current
version of our that you're running if
there are assistant dependencies of
those packages and a write a docker for
you so you just read your session F
throw it writes that docker file it can
that you can just build that image and
usually it gets all the default or up
those defaults right for you and grab
the right rocker image of the base and
it has a little components for you so
that's super helpful you don't have to
write every docker file there's another
version of this specifically for our
markdown documents if you don't to have
lots of files lying around you just
trying to compress everything into one
file there's a package called lifter
lifter just lets you put all your docker
associated metadata in that yellow
header of your docker file so in
addition to your title and author and
date and what the one looks like you
just have a lifter field and you can say
you know what your basis of the v-rocker
file is whether you need panda to build
things whether
tech to build things and what your
system dependencies are or packages
installed from different repositories so
that too will create a docker file and
lifter haves command render docker which
will fire up the docker file run the
render command to get your output you
know shut it all down and then rather
than just knitting or rendering your our
markdown in your current environment
it's happening in the environment it's
defined in the header of the file so it
tries to get all of that sort of docker
workflow into just you know that button
that says knit at the top of those
things both help you at the end of
setting up your doctor environment but
you also may want to distribute it and
there's this fantastic tool called
binder binder was originally designed
for distributing Jupiter notebook but
does our studio or all sorts of other
environments now as well I don't
remember exactly how they fund this but
if you have a hub repository with a
docker file in it defining a Jupiter or
our studio environment binder will
simply launch a server running that
image for you for free it's not the like
most you know resource extensive one but
it's great for letting anyone else toy
around with analysis that you have and
so if your analysis is open source for
instance and we published a paper on
ecological noise phenomena and he just
has a link in here for launch binder all
that does is send binder the URL of the
repository and so this is just a bad you
add to your repository you do that it
takes you to binder it will fire up the
repository it's pulling the image it
launches a server and in a minute here
you will end up with that same our
studio environment
that Karl used to do the analysis that
he ran his did the analysis that he used
to publish that paper and so this year
is his research repository the version
of our that he was using all the
packages that he was using in student
custom ones and we've got the paper
itself as in our markdown file that you
can remember or you could grab the code
and do it yourself there's sort of
layers to this and that you could grab
that code and try to run it on your own
computer but if it's not working for you
the dependency problems this lets you
get there instantly and you don't need
any infrastructure and it's a good
example of your really deploying this
reproducible container as a service for
people to use another example of how you
might try to sort of package up work
environment maybe you want to create a
container that is common for the tools
and the problems that your team is using
so EcoHealth we have a container called
reservoir reservoir is based off the
geospatial rocker project but it has a
bunch of other machine learning and a
bunch of other sort of commission
communication tools within it it runs on
our high-performance server it also runs
on our new high-performance server so I
didn't have to configure that server I
just move the move the image over so the
same thing works there if we need to
spin up an environment with different
resources on Amazon if our local stuff
goes down we need to move to the cloud
the container is available to use so it
has sort of the things we commonly use
on a day to day basis and if I need to
update it I gave that in the docker file
and then like bringing the server down
to do it I like to make sure the docker
if I on bills run in a different place
and then when it's working well I just
shut down the old image and start up the
new one and so that makes sure that we
have a common environment that we could
work in in different places and it's
also a good way to nanny
a common working environment for people
this reproducibility box isn't actually
why docker was early originally designed
though docker was designed as a way of
firing up and delivering services in
sort of rapid ways so one of ours great
advantage is his ability to work with
things that are not hard when like s was
created the idea was to provide access
to compiled statistical libraries in
Fortran and C and as time has gone on R
has had a lot more connectors different
types of things in Java and in Python
and to web services and you can think of
docker as a way to package up anything
that were to run in a Linux box as a
service that are can call and so you
might do this sort of a custom as for a
custom service yourself you have an API
that you want to run locally that are
can connect to and then there are also
packages that are specifically built
around the idea that there is a service
or a server in docker that you want to
run so some of those include browser
rendering services for web scraping so
splasher and Sallee and selenium are
both frameworks for web scraping that
have a server that's running a headless
browser and a series of commands to
control that browser and a bunch of
software software to render and transfer
information from that browser for either
testing apps or web scraping so those
live in a docker container that in our
package calls there's another neat one
called the open source arriving machine
which is basically a sort of a Google
Max Maps our app finder using Open
Street Map data so it's a series of
libraries that live in a docker
container that you can communicate with
they have a version on the web you can
call it you know the website but that's
slower and they have only so much
capacity but you can just run the whole
thing locally on your machine to pull
those to pull those routes and then you
know machine learning services like h2o
if anyone's familiar using h2o h2o is a
job application Java applications can be
difficult to get configured properly and
installation but you can run it h2o in a
docker image and do all the same things
and you don't have to you know work with
different versions of Java installation
so if we're to use docker to run
something like a web scraping service
we're not building an image what we're
doing is we're pulling an image using
and communicating with that image and
that image has nothing to do with our
itself doesn't have our installed as
whatever splash has which says some
combination of Python and something else
I don't actually remember and it doesn't
really matter so if I want to use
something like this I can load up my
stevedore library to control docker
containers and then the splash our
package which is what communicates over
the doctor client and then I just create
a container as a goal or will be pulled
from docker hub if I need it I say which
ports to open I see that container
running on my machine with sort of steam
you can query the container that about
it you can get you know that it's
running you know the name never started
that you can issue commands on the
container that way and now the commands
in the splash package they are just
sending HTTP requests to that container
to tell it what to do and get
information back so this is an example
where we're visiting the CDC website
that shows flu cases gets the website
and maybe you want to get this graph but
you have to get past this disclaimer and
you want to display
with splat that we're running on our
local computer at the port 8050 because
that's what we opened up in the back
sort of hole type of you know
fire it up to visit the way press ENTER
and so when I run that our is just
sending commands back and forth rather
than to a server on the web to a server
running on your own machine the sort of
micro service and it's waiting a bit so
that at the CDC you can load but it just
is in the end will you know return the
image of the website that I'm looking
for they might be doing all sorts of
other things grabbing the table scraping
the data processing it but rather than
installing splash and there's Python
dependencies all those things we run
splash in the container when you're done
you can stop a container you can check
that container has exited and actually
made this thing a little more complex
more complex than I need to for
demonstration purposes because the
splash package itself just has a command
start splash that does this and if you
look inside it they're actually using
the docker around the stevedore package
but the syntax is almost exactly the
same it's firing up the client starting
the image and returning that so you can
run all of that and then there's a stop
splash container that does the same
thing
so that's what you do when you have are
on the outside and another service on
the inside like this we want to call all
of these other programs that you want to
package up and not deal with
installation but then you can go the
other way around you can have are inside
a box and then you want to deliver
services or data or other things to a
different program to a website to a
different framework where people are
pulling data from or just sort of
deliver your data sources or your models
especially to some larger some larger
software framework some larger app or
web service that needs to call your our
program but our is not part of you know
what your Web Services team works with
but in docker package is what a Web
Services team could totally work with
they're like oh yeah we can run that
it's on this port when our Python or
JavaScript or other components needs to
call this they'll just ask the question
on the port will get the number back the
predictor the chart that you generated
any of those things and so they're a
bunch of different types of our services
you might create probably the one you're
most familiar for most people are most
from their site you generate a web app
so you can have a web app in a docker
container that can run anywhere there's
another similar framework called firey
which is like a much more low-level uh
opinionated way to generate generate
websites tomorrow or you might not be
delivering and interact and interactive
user facing thing you might be
delivering services and the REST API is
for a different group to work with you
can do that with an program call a
package called plumber or another one
called open CPU both for developing REST
API s and then what we did before
showing the arse to do the environment
or a similar Jupiter environment those
are sort of environments delivered as
services as well so you know
in addition to just you know having that
package product you are delivering a
service of letting people work on it for
you as well so all of these things are
different ways you might want something
that is are running in a box that can
move around that other people can access
you want it I stole this one from flop
sort of a typical shiny program we have
a bunch of library calls the top two
define what we need we do some
pre-processing of data there's a user
interface component and a service
component in this case the shiny program
just demonstrates some of the
interactivity and crosstalk that you can
have between data tables and plotly and
so you put that all together it exports
of shiny app Johnny Apple runs funnier
machine how do we get that shiny app to
other places well once again we define a
docker file so in this case again I'm
going to start the doctor from a tidy
verse so I have all those packages
available tagged with my name and then
install the packages using the shiny
shiny apps so I have DT and pop Li and
crosstalk you know shiny itself here
because I have this other line which has
a sort of confusing component and this
comes from the rocker project itself has
set up a command that installs shiny and
all the shiny server dependencies so you
can add shiny to any of the rocker
images so you might want the tidy verse
image with shiny you might want the
debian edge version with shiny or you
may may want an older version with shiny
so you just run this Abdus command with
in the rocker documentation you get
shiny at at your package and then you
import your app itself and put in the
shiny servers serving directory so we
can fire this up this time I'll do it
from our as the Michelle I load
stevedore and the docker client you're
gonna build off of the shiney directory
and call it shap it runs all of those
commands so now we have a built in inch
which we call shap and then we can run
shaft as the container and go to it now
so the shiny container on port 3 88 is
running this slot the app which have
talked package select to view
interactive selection and so if you're
building something that's to live going
to you know a user 15 this can be
website maybe just ends up you know you
know like in a frame within a larger
component of your organization's site or
maybe you're like well I've written this
but I have no idea how to deploy it what
if it have to be pull a lot of people
you know sort of a development
operations group can just take this and
like oh yeah we can set this up so we
can scale and there'll be a thousand
instances of it so every time it gets to
have too many people will fire up a new
one
all they have to do is are on the docker
container and have that trigger that
stop that
I have another demo year of plumber if
you're building an API where you want to
serve predictions or data plumbers are
relatively it's been around a while they
really only invest in well recently it
comes from Japan who's in our studio
it lets you define functions that will
act as REST API endpoints so you can
send EKKO to this service and it will
return and echo over the message saying
this message is which is not super
exciting
you can send plot and you'll get a
random plot you can send some and
parameters and add some numbers to it
but if you can write a function you can
write a function that generates
predictions from your XG boost model and
so someone who's wearing the service to
generate a mob saying what's the
prediction of the you know best pizza
restaurant that you're looking for you
can just have a function R that does
that deliver it as a service and then of
course we want that service to integrate
with someone's site through being a
docker in India and so we'll just pull
the plumber docker image does all the
Plumber dependencies in it tag it at our
app this is a particular modification of
what the startup command is in this
docker image which says fire up plumber
and I just added this because it lets me
add this swagger command here which
shows which automatically generates
swagger documentation for my API and
then we run the app itself
so
in this case we'll put it on let's see
build it here put it on the port I guess
I ran it twice so it says ports already
allocated because we already have one so
this one at 4,000 is festive chebyshev
and if we visit that i have a web
service that delivers an image every
time someone calls this API endpoint
refresh we have that our process running
is returning an object to you you know
you know you can also say add with
parameters a equals three and B equals
five and you get this very budget here
not have some it's a very exciting
response but it's the same service and
no one cares what's running underneath
that service is the main point and no
one cares exactly how to install the
things you have both the output and the
startup are just pluggable and sort of
anyone's web infrastructure finally
let's see
if you're just like with lifter or
container it if you're building a shiny
app and it has a bunch of dependencies
and you want to create a complex docker
file to make sure all those pieces are
there
the Ryze package does that for shiny
apps it finds all the pieces necessary
for the shiny after on it assembles your
docker file you know might have to you
know all of these you might have to
tweak or maybe you have an efficiency
improvement but they give you a really
great start the final thing you might
want to use docker for is deploying big
compute jobs so doctor container is
something that can move between
infrastructures and so if you have a big
job that needs to use a bunch of
different cloud services or a bunch of
different computers you can send that
job in the form of a docker file and get
the results back and so if you something
that really needs to scale up in terms
of compute docker is a way to do it
often you don't have to build the images
and send them because that
infrastructure has at least docker
installed on it so you can build and run
the containers there rather than build
them and send them along I'm not going
to go through a detailed example here
but this is one I was actually just
working on the other day for some of my
own Slough this stuff if you're familiar
with the future package for parallel
computing it's a really sort of great
framework for sending jobs to any
background process and getting it back
and so I had set up a thing where I made
a cluster of multiple computers on my
network and then it has this one
parameter called our script and normally
that just says what's the command to run
our on that machine so when we send they
when we send the commands we can run
that command on that machine
rather than having a path to our itself
I said run a docker image and around our
and so when I send a job to that it will
fire up the docker image or run
there and send the results back so it's
something you would send a big job to
you don't want to send something fire
but docker image you know add ten
numbers together and get them back but
if you have something that's
long-running you know this is a good way
you can just integrate this into
something that you might already have
sort of a standard say no send it to
that computer and use docker to run our
rather than on my computer to do
something else this works with a lot of
services the future package itself has
like templates for doing this
specifically already with Amazon Web
there's been Google compute and it
probably works with a juror and I should
probably figure that out at some point
there's a packaged Google compute R that
has like pre-built docker templates for
Google compute our O's docker service
you're just like send this docker
template with this one additional
component to the job and it'll build the
image fire the job up there and get
things back which is really great as
well if you are deploying big jobs
there's actually a very similar 'native
which you might want to consider there's
a program called singularity that is a
very similar portable container set up
to docker and as it's sort of
specifically designed for this big
compute delivery service kind of thing
some of the important differences are
that you don't need admin rights on any
machine to run it so you know it might
not just be that you on some machine you
can't install are you also can't install
docker and it's not pre-installed you're
using someone's cluster or supercomputer
can pull down singularity and a run it
at the user with no they're not
basically for running a service they've
done for designed for running a workflow
or a batch job or some utility one time
and so they tend to have access to the
filesystem someone said like docker is
like an alternate universe but
singularity are parallel universes that
have you know occasional ships in the
timeline so it's more like it'll take
your current machine and
pull out the operating system and put a
different one underneath it I haven't
actually used it but some the important
thing is it can run the docker images
too so you can grab a docker image in
your honor within the singularity you
don't have to build up everything you
scratch you can still use the rocker
project or something else and but I put
it in because when I posted this today
honoring thanks a created the future
package and there's a lot of state
computer no next jobs San Francisco
State doing biomedical work said you
know doing the big compute stuff is a
lot easier on singularities so it's not
my endorsement but it's definitely a
possibility
because a lot of people like it as well
I'm going to post the slides and
actually a whole bunch of links to
different things that I talked about
online as well so there's gonna be a lot
more than this but docker has really
great and comprehensive documentation
you have to remember that it's like
written primarily for people who are
building web services and doing large
conformed container orchestration who
are not necessarily thinking about the
data scientists are all how we are doing
it up inside put together a lot more oh
you're not everything you do there is no
sorry the same you do it now but it's a
good introduction to the process and
then have students go to walk through
and said everything that will be up
tomorrow at my github with York docker
talk so thank you very much and I'm
happy
[Applause]
well
[Music]
I mean in terms of other I mean the city
there's a huge number of projects that
are using
[Music]
um I think only singularity doug's if I
have it right
vagrant works with docker is an
orchestration package so it will run
virtual machines and it will also run
docker images so it's a more general
thing then there's also like there's all
these add-on students for machine that
are to the various and then serve to
hold off the operating system you set up
configuring this sort of multiple but I
think well me singularity will run
docker images visit or creation so that
containers would be interoperable that I
followed enough honestly to tell you if
there's any more than that
I don't know what any of those things
are yeah
[Music]
necessarily load what is like the docker
environment into another environment per
se there are things you can share
between your computer and the doctor in
front of it so you can share directories
between docker and your computer so you
can mount the directory in say this data
directory this project directory when I
run say our studio a Jupiter and docker
there'll be a folder there and that's
the folder that's also on my machine so
like typically what I end up doing if I
have seen as a that sort of has a docker
environment because I'm running our
studio through that and I run that
through the browser but I'm running on
files in my machine just I'm running
those off that moving sort of the
environment component out I don't think
you can do so because that's what sort
of indices to use that environment on
other projects that live on your machine
I mean honestly what I what I typically
do is I'm running locally and then I run
it also in the docker container to make
sure that everything is is appropriate
right so like I can be a little fast and
loose on you know the ongoing basis but
you know before I want to commit it up
before I want to transfer it I'm making
sure things are running in the docker
environment is that's the
standardization and so you might do that
interactively or sort of a common
pattern is just to use a docker a doc or
driven commands to run your tests so all
the tests occur in the docker and then
you get them back and that's fine and
you don't necessarily have to be running
image all the time in your ongoing to
the development
[Music]
so there it's a lot less than you know
sort of a virtual machine one of the
biggest things it used to be and it's
gotten much better that like that fought
that movement between file systems and
so mounting the docker file system on
the Mac file system meant that reading
and writing lots of files got
particularly slow that's less the case
though it's still a little bit one of
the bottlenecks but the thing is you
don't have separate memory like the
thing about the difference between
docker and having like a total isolated
virtual machine and this which is
actually just isolating processes is
that really lowers the overhead on
things related to like RAM and CPU
access and we really don't get much of a
penalty at all
I've been trying out some cases recently
with looking at GPU and making sure that
docker on GP on GPU machines are unwell
and that's like all like at least you
know well over 95% of what the
performances on the raw machines so
that's you know that's the reason this
has become popular it's like that
overhead problem is what people want it
to solve in order to be able to scale
things up
I guess it really depends you know like
how much you care about performance and
you know sort of what you're like if all
purple performances all you care about
right like you know you know your
optimization space like it's all over
towards performance it's a little bit
but it's a pretty minor for the most
part and you know really the case with
specialized hardware is the case where
you're more likely to run into that so
you know it's a matter of priorities
so if I remember right and I'm not sure
about this Gabor Azhar who's a member of
our studio team and the creator of a
huge number of packages one of the
things he did is when he was building a
project called our hub
he built a database of all the system
dependencies for packages on kram and so
you know you go to a cran web page and
it's like you need looks live XML -
that's dev in order to install this
package and so it was a matter of like
scraping all those files and building
that database and maintaining it and so
that service lose at this point so when
you get a package you can query the our
hub database if I remember this
correctly and that's how you get system
into dependencies that he's installing
it there's way through app to get on you
know on Linux Debian Debian a UNIX
Oh
right so does it I mean this is there's
lots of ways so right so I mean one
option is that you just pull like the
docker you don't need the wherever you
have those things right like at some
places the place you have the code base
right so the private repository where
you have the code you're also pulling in
data from other places in that private
repository with the code you have the
docker file and so the first thing you
do for big ass simulation on is build
off the dick docker file and run it and
you just have to say docker on that
directory and it will first you know
build a docker file and then around the
command essentially so that's option one
if like building the thing takes a long
time because you have a big ass compile
before you're a big ass simulation then
right and you just want that compile to
like happen in the build stage then you
probably an s3 can store as a blob the
image itself right and then you can say
pull the image from blob or my paid
docker hub accounts or anything along
those lines and you're gonna pull down
that image which might be you know like
three gigabytes of system dependencies
and you know operating system and then I
run it yeah and you could also put the
data in that image too if you want to
say building the image includes
importing the data and one of the
you can move that around if that's not
sort of that active of
[Music]
[Music]
I'm like oh so you have a work flow and
we're talking about an interactive work
flow and that's like we're running a
pipeline and it's coming out right I
mean now it's like you have your spun
off docker environment people use that
son of doctor environment and then like
you know if you were working in an
interact without dog you know we're just
there we just have slightly different
versions we are then you have to have a
place that you're you know you can push
those to a cup you can be get pod or
maybe you are producing things that are
you know big blog and say we have an s3
storage container that we share and so
here donor on your analysis you push up
there if you're not mounting the local
volume you have to do that because
otherwise when you shut down your docker
image it's going the way or you run off
your you know you run off you when you
fire up your running mount through the
local directory and even when you shut
down those files are still there but if
you have an interactive workflow to do
have an interactive step of sending
those outputs some place as well and so
you sort of have to do that same thing
be it in a docker environment or not
so your so you have different you can
have different versions in a given a
repo so I'll give you actually that's
way to do this is if I go to pub let's
go to rocker version right so rocker our
version is the the repo within that repo
there are all of these different
versions of it you know for all the
different are versions
um it's not forking per se there are two
ways to there are two ways to get an
image different ways to get in
development dog forever or maybe three
you can have an automated build which
points to a github repo or something
similar and that's just pointing to
where our docker file is and docker hub
will automatically run that docker file
build the image every time it changes
over there so I keep it git repo I can
add different subfolders or branches and
I can say for each of those branches or
repos build something and give it a
different tag also you can just build
something and push it and you can give
it a different tag within the same repo
so what a rocker does and what I do is
actually like I use a different CI
service I use Circle CI
I push up there I run the image I test
it and when it's done it pushes it to
docker hub to make sure it's there and
there's two versions of those cuz I have
one of those that's like GPU enabled and
once not you GPU enabled so it builds
both of those pushes one with the GPU
tag one without the GPU tag
okay
I will
throw away their Piper's thank you Thank
You Jerry